when you go out are people demanding
that you dance
yes as they answer i
after i did step up not even magic mike
but like every time i would go to a bar
or a club somebody would be like yo i'll
battle you bro i'll battle you and
it was a movie it was a movie people got
paid to lose in those battles like i i
don't i can't know but also you know
what i love is they will battle you in
dance yeah you know i never understand
how that works in real life if someone's
battling me in a dance i just won't
concede that they're better than me
right
i'll just keep dancing
and what but people in dance-offs when
someone doesn't move they're just like
ah
you win i can't top that
that's great so you actually have dance
battles with people yes well no no
they request them they request them i
don't actually you will not do them uh
jonah impressive stunts in this movie uh
channing
obviously has a lot of practice doing
stunts you probably not so much with the
stunts
did he advise you did he give you help
well we've made two of these jump street
movies now
and
i've developed a theory called
chanting's the crash test dummy so
if there's a stun and we're both
supposed to do it
i watch him do it he does it first and
if he doesn't get very badly hurt then
i'll try and do it
and if he gets really hurt i'll say hey
maybe you know we could rewrite this
scene a little bit
to where i do something else right right
yeah like i take a nap
there's a scene where you are literally
you're hanging upside down it's early in
the movie you're hanging upside down off
of a truck right and that looked like
you were really hanging upside down off
a moving truck yeah that was the worst
of the stunt stuff i think because your
blood just all rushes to your head and
we're g for a couple days and finally i
got like really sick and i couldn't do
it anymore and so they go oh okay we'll
just put the thing on the floor and you
just lay on it and we'll turn the camera
upside down
which
he did and it looked exactly the same
meaning that i never even had to go
upside down in the first place no yeah
best thing is i knew that that was
actually possible i just wouldn't let
them tell him that yeah
he knew that at the end you were
attacking his low thigh the whole time
off camera yeah
uh jonah you said you would rather do
stunts than act with birds you hate
birds
i don't hate birds you hate doing acting
with birds i don't like acting with
birds
i'm jealous of their ability of flight
and
we were shooting a scene and i got
attacked by a bird pretty viciously i'm
not gonna lie like
the bird even understood that certain
people have this thing that you just
want to attack them like i have with
jonah i want to cause harm right he had
the same exact reaction and literally
flew at jonah's face and attacked it
yeah he was like the chanting of birds
because
he was strong and sensitive
but when it came down to it
he knew how to cause pain
so i think we have this scene the bird
attacks you oh please yeah show it why
not yeah that's cool i think we have
this but let's see this clip where a
bird really attacked you i don't think
this was supposed to happen but let's
take a look i can tell you it was not
supposed to there's a dragon in here
[Laughter]
[Applause]
all right by the way i've seen this guy
laugh harder in my entire life
than that moment that's the trick you
admitted it's the streak it is
well
for real real talk i hope this is real
talk
oh i better put this away yes please
um
i was 20 so i do have a fear of birds
like
for real and i when i was 20 i was out
to dinner with my with my lunch for my
with my girlfriend at the time's parents
the younger brother was uh graduating
from high school and all the men in the
family were very alpha male jocks and
stuff and we were eating by the beach
and a bird flew at me and i screamed
exactly like that and fell out of my
chair and i lost the man's respect for
the rest of the relationship
i never recovered there's no way back
from something like that no man but
honestly birds like i i just i don't
feel the need to like
like
they're
they they can go fly away and live
somewhere else for all i care you know
it doesn't no birds were hurt in the
filming of this movie yeah no you were
hurt but no birds humans were hurt in
the making
when they screamed the movie for birds
they should have that little disclaimer